we talked about at the beginning of the
show and it looks like the fellas had a
lot to say about it finding love is not
that easy right and it's especially hard
in this economy and guess what many
women say they aren't finding it very
hard to find a man who makes as much as
they do a study by Cornell University
found that the country's declining
marriage rate is due to the lack of
financially eligible bachelors women are
actually outpacing men with education
and this is changing the age-old
mentality that men are the breadwinners
it turned and turned the gig or small
gigs economy and lack of good jobs out
there have left the ladies single and
disgruntled every searchers say they are
seeing a trend of women dating down when
men do is with breadwinners when women
do it their what their dating down okay
but she acknowledged she acknowledged
that the fact that it was wrong and it
was probably a joke let me give her that
just the reality of it so women you know
we're more educated now and I think they
were furthering our education so with
that being said we're gonna hold off on
the baby-making we're gonna hold off
until we get that great job really
career driven and I don't think there's
anything wrong with hoping that there's
someone either on your level or higher
than you so okay all right so before
right it was okay when the man made more
money to be the one to buy everything to
do you know treat you and all this other
kind stuff and now that you make more
money you can't be that one right you
can't be the one to pay for the meal and
because you're dating down I do your
thing with a man cuz you're dating down
I hate that what is that about you
wouldn't call Dean I think that this
face perfectly embodies maybe like you
talked about in a girl because you're
dating down I hate that what is that
about you wouldn't call dating down yeah
men were the breadwinners what is that I
have a feeling though that some of the
issue here is that it may be the psyche
of the men that when they make less they
are insecure and women sent complaining
about the fact they did not buy it you
try to do the whole sliparooni well it's
really because of you so we no no we not
complaining you is about are these women
expecting the men to cover everything
they want those breadwinners so that's
what it sounds like the me by this to go
to study I have the day down now what is
that you wanted to make more money you
make more money what's the if there is a
responsibility with making more money
first of all I don't believe in any of
it but if there's a responsibility that
comes with making more money accept it
you wanted to make more money and my
point is so now you're going to because
we hear so much about women that are
like oh there's nobody out there there's
no one out there I can't find love I'm
getting jewel
now you're gonna sacrifice the fact that
you could find that love because the
man's not making that much money are you
gonna take down feeling this is gonna be
our morning rush action left to say all
right time now 5:11 that's you know I
think the idea that you're dating down
because someone makes less than you it's
kind of weird because people can
contribute to relationships in ways
other than just financially I mean
preach do not have the same roles in
this partnership
right but we both contribute to it in
ways that are very very meaningful and
as a result we value what the other
person brings I wouldn't say I'm
working down or whatever because someone
doesn't have a specific skillset that I
have to say well I don't have his skill
set in certain areas
do women dislike dating down I believe
so but you have to contextualize that
because women don't want to date down
not just financially but in other ways
women want to date men who are taller
than them women we want to date men who
are their age or older and women
generally date men who have their income
level or above that is affect and what
we like it's not me saying that what do
we like these are known statistics and
I'm not judging I'm not saying women or
gold-digging I'm not saying that I think
these are the standards that women
generally live we are shallow on
different things we know that men and
women put on different [ __ ] you would
say must be the money hey must be there
what do you say to the women who say
yeah we date men who are taller than us
or above because of the fact that men
don't feel comfortable dating women who
are taller them obviously don't but I
understand there's something like that
there's definitely some men who feel
comfortable it makes them insecure but
here's what I also tell you I know a lot
of talking and one thing all tall women
tell me is that they get annoyed when
really short guys keep constantly of the
oshika because you're like why are you
wasting your time so what that indicates
to me is not that there aren't a bunch
of short men who aren't willing to date
tall women it's that we just don't want
them I've never seen a tall woman go to
a sport maybe like inside no it should
be illegal for women to wear heels
because you can't on one hand complain
about not finding men who are taller
than you and then for some reason make
yourself arbitrarily taller for a few
hours when you go out where you're
supposed to meet men then you eliminate
man that doesn't make any sense you
supposed to be you supposed to meet so
three feet three feet tall and you're 6
foot 7 foot 8 foot tall if anybody
should be wearing heels in this world
it's men men should be the only ones
allowed to wear heels it should be us
Maggie's going around like
you never done that before
do that boo boo
usually they called me gay about the [ __ ]
what you guys have never never put on
your shoes and you're too lazy to like
sleep on the back so you put your heel
on the back end of the shoe and you
start dragging you for like rub yeah you
got your purse yeah you start dragging
all right stop following what though if
you only date people at your level or
above and if men are only used to dating
women who are beneath them in terms of
income that fool you are inherently
making your field of play really small
the opportunities that you're gonna have
are gonna be limited let me put it this
way right if if there are a hundred
women who make fifty thousand dollars
and there are a hundred men who make
fifty thousand dollars right if these
100 men only did will believe their
income level they're not gonna look it
right so you're gonna have to look at
the income level above generally
speaking okay and so if you are trying
to date men who make let's say 80 K
right but there's only 50 of them and
there's a hundred women here making
fifty K then yeah there's going to only
be fifty men for those hundred women and
here's the worst part those fifty men
don't necessarily want to date you they
may want to date women who are making 10
K or 20 K they don't give a [ __ ] cuz
they're not looking at income level when
they choose our partner and so if you're
only dating men who are above you or at
your level you are severely limiting the
potential partners that you may have
based only on how much money they make
and how much they can bring and I don't
want anyone in the comments to say that
financial security is not really
important because seventy to ninety one
percent of all divorces come and are
initiated by women and majority of those
divorces are done for financial reasons
for financial security a lot of people
are finding it hard to date but I'm like
if it is hard for you why would you make
it extra difficult by adding these extra
barriers to you finding a bundle I know
it's like yeah I'm thinking tired of
being lonely I'm sick and tired of being
lonely while they dad dude he's not tall
enough take that dude he's he's too
light they
that dude he he's got a belly they'd
that dude
oh you used to be a fat dude they dead
and I'm not even exaggerating that's
what the person and I'm like girl the
problem is not then from is you oh yeah
we want to get your thoughts do you guys
disagree with the idea of dating down do
you agree with it
[Music]
but like I am setting the old ways like
I'm a very old-school person on like I
will pay like 50/50 but I'd rather pay
fifty-fifty on like bills and stuff and
have my partner pay for fun like if we
go to the restaurant or whatever doesn't
mean that you pay more but I'd rather
you pay for that and I pay for the bills
even if it's 50/50 I feel like special
know what I mean like it's not like I
want my partner to pay for everything
yeah so I was in a relationship with a
girl in the past and she we had the same
money but I was like girl you paying
when we go through the restaurants
you're paying when we go out no we're
too feminine woman okay yeah I told her
she would yeah I was like I'm gonna yes
[Laughter]
coz I'm still 5050
even with my my boyfriend now it's the
same thing like when we go out I want to
be like and then you're paying there is
none yeah but there's plastic so that's
done
Touche put that [ __ ] in microwave
there's no difference for me no I've
been in a weird relationship with a gay
man once and I've never felt so
unappreciated physically but it was
great we used to have sex kinda sorta
but we used to like go out like it's a
Saturday night you don't have nothing I
don't have enough thing we're going out
together it was that kind of
relationship
it was weird it was very weird there was
any heart so how it started I met that
guy and he told me he was gay and we
started talking because he started
talking to me because he was trying to
get with my gay friend okay and then and
he said I asked him how do you know
you're gay he's like I just know and I
was like have you ever had sex with a
woman he was like no that she's
disgusting and I was like boy you gotta
try that at least once and I'm perfect
candidate cuz even though you're gay I
like that and it was like okay so we
tried that's true I've told that before
like you know like you need to try at
least once but that's the pansexual in
me I'm like the garbage of the six world
like oh you nobody wants you I want you
okay but like no I know that everybody
that's pansexual is not like that but I
am very like that so and it was like
yeah well I never tried because I was
scared that like feelings and whatever
and I was scared that if I really hate
it in the moment I'm gonna have to be
like this is disgusting I have to go I'm
gonna hurt the girls feeling right so I
was like you can try he's like because
he's dead and he told me he wanted to
try but yeah I was of course and so he
tried and it was very long before
anything happened
no it was very long before he started to
have anything going on so then I had to
like role play that [ __ ] and like mad so
it finally happened but I had to like
act as if I was a guy
[Laughter]